bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8
week-end vous le savez c'est tous les
vendredis votre magazine dédié aux
loisirs nous allons parler cette semaine
de la base de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines un programme
qui se peaufine pour l'été du festival
mémoire d'étoiles qui se déroule à
Bois-d'Arcy et puis d'une compétition de
tir à l'arc en trois dimensions mais oui
ça existe du côté de Manille les hameau
donc du bon dans autour de moi pour
cette émission on va commencer avec à la
base de loisirs l'été va être riche à la
base de loisirs si le beau temps se
maintient en plus ça veut dire qu'il y a
ça promet de vraiment de belles journées
pour en parler Frédéric Bordier demain
soir directeur de la base de loisirs et
Vincent couteau bonsoir responsable des
animations du territoire alors pour
parler de toutes les activités de l'été
il y en a beaucoup on va commencer
peut-être par la plus symbolique Vincent
c'est la piscine à vague ça y est c'est
reparti pour une saison
la semaine prochaine donc la piscine à
vague ouvre ses portes le 5 juillet avec
son lot d'animation multiple parce que
tous les jours il y aura une dizaine
d'animations
gratuite voire plus même sur l'ensemble
de l'été donc les gens viennent déjà
frapper à la porte de la piscine faut
être un tout petit peu passion mais elle
sera à 26 degrés comme l'an dernier
je sais
pas si facile toutes les heures toutes
les heures il y a 10 à 15 minutes de
vagues c'est de la houle en fait donc on
a vraiment tous d'être au bord de mer
parce qu'il y a une grande plage verte
en plus on pouvait venir avec votre
votre pique-nique votre serviette
profitez du soleil et puis vous baignez
donc soit pour ma période de vagues soit
en dehors de la période donc 10 minutes
toutes les heures et ça coûte combien ça
par exemple il faut s'acquitter le droit
d'entrée effectivement c'est juste donc
l'entrée à base de loisirs est gratuite
je le rappelle il y a uniquement le
parking qui est payant c'est 4 euros
pour la journée par voiture et sinon
donc le l'entrée de la piscine à vague
tourne entre 5 euros et 7 euros selon la
période de la semaine et le nombre de
personnes et cet été aussi les visiteurs
pour en profiter du village
sportifs
et c'est un grand une grande cage en
fait
en filet avec des buts de chaque côté ça
joue au pied et à la main c'est une
activité vraiment vraiment fun donc je
vous invite à la découvrir c'est un
mélange de fou dehors
ça joue de compte deux ou trois contre
trois voilà c'est assez sportif et c'est
sympa et dans ce village sportif il y a
aussi d'autres activités il y aura de la
zumba il y aura de la sarbacane de la
PTK un sport qui devient du Brésil du
samba aussi
un petit mot aussi sur l'accrobranche
puisque évidemment ça a lieu cet été
donc il y a des soirées nocturnes
exactement donc le Parcours Acrobatique
en Hauteur parce que c'est ce qui c'est
ce qu'il faut dire et ouvert toute
l'année et donc en l'occurrence on met
en place cette année vu le succès de
l'an dernier les acronytes donc on était
les premiers à faire ça donc de du
parcours acrobatique de nuit avec des
lampes frontales et surtout des lampes
ultraviolettes donc avec du masque
phosphorescents donc c'est toute une
atmosphère de nuit qui est vraiment ça
ça cartonne tous les mois
l'impression je pense avoir l'impression
quoi de flotter moins difficile pour
pour les gens qui ont peur du vide donc
c'est plus accessible et puis on est
dans une atmosphère on est au milieu de
la forêt on est près de l'étang donc on
a de temps en temps on a une super vue
sur les temps on
exactement le niveau de la nuit c'est
vraiment vraiment top et c'est une fois
par mois voilà c'est une fois par mois
c'est le 4 juillet pour ceux qui veulent
la première séance du mois de juillet et
pour ceux qui ne sont pas là au mois de
juillet mais qui sont là au mois d'août
l'autre séance aura lieu le 29 août
exactement voilà donc ça c'est
l'accrobranche de nuit on va aller du
côté de la réserve naturelle qui ouvre
peu ses portes mais qui organise quand
même un camp de vacances cet été oui
tout à fait le camp archéo donc il y
aura lieu au mois de juillet et donc on
a encore des places donc inscrivez
inscrivez-vous en juillet
donc le principe c'est vraiment toute
l'équipe de réserve naturelle qui est
qui avec les jeunes sous des tipis et
donc qui vont regarder les traces des
animaux faire toutes nos séries
d'animation autour de autour de ça alors
ça c'est réservé aux enfants de 8 à 12
ans c'est exemple la réserve naturelle
alors c'est il y a des activités qui
sont au sein de la réserve par contre on
ne peut pas dormir au sein de la
respiration comme le lieu l'indique
c'est vraiment un espace complètement
protégé donc ils dorment au sein de la
ferme pédagogique donc à côté des tipis
à côté des animaux de la ferme et par
contre ils vont faire des animations
dans la réserve naturelle donc du 9 au
11 juillet et il reste encore des places
si vous voulez aller dormir sous les
tipis c'est sympa ça des petits pics
exactement s'il fait beau bien sûr
parfois il va faire beau alors un petit
mot aussi sur on va aussi parler des
centres de voile centre équestre parce
que pas d'animation particulière pour
l'été mais ils sont ouverts ils
organisent des des stages notamment tout
à fait il y a des stages tous l'été donc
à la fois les les weekends et la semaine
donc des stages pour les enfants mais
aussi pour les adultes donc n'hésitez
pas à vous renseigner ça peut être la
journée ça peut être au week-end ça peut
être sur plusieurs weekends et au niveau
de la voile et donc au niveau du centre
équestre on organise des balades nature
par exemple des sorties voilà d'une
heure et demie de 2 heures des cours
aussi d'initiation donc voilà donc ça
reste ouvert tout l'été si vous êtes
passionnés de voile ou de Chev des
chevaux et de voile pareil voilà vous
avez des animations qui sont proposées
dans le centre de World santé caisse un
petit mot sur le judo tour ça c'est du
15 au 17 juillet à faire du judo à la
base de loisirs exactement
ils reviennent sur notre base pendant 3
jours donc ce sera le 15 et 17 juillet
au sein de la piscine avec l'animation
gratuite une fois que vous êtes dans la
piscine à vague et le sel ce sera au
milieu du parc note donc de la zone
piétonne la près du centre équestre de
location de vélo et de Rosalie et donc
là c'est gratuit pour tout le monde de
11h à 17h pour le pour le mercredi
des brevets d'état professionnels qui
viennent qui encadre on a aussi des
champions de France qui sont présents
pour faire des démonstrations donc nous
savons accessible à tout le monde petit
écrans peut-être
on va se aller on va se projeter un
petit peu sur la rentrée de cette
septembre des nouveautés pour cette base
de loisirs toute l'année
mais pour la rentrée non on attend
plusieurs grands projets enfin en tout
cas le plus gros projet que je pense
tout de suite c'est notre accessibilité
à la base de loisirs puisque en
septembre commence les travaux de
l'entrée de Trappes on trouvera
maintenant 4 voies d'accès dont une
dédiée aux adhérents du golf une dédiée
au secours et deux autres pour le tout
public
à l'entrée à l'entrée de la base à
l'intérieur de la base et en même temps
la manière de de payer le moyen de
paiement carte bleue sans contact carte
sans contact
pardon sans code carte sans contact
paiement billet monnaie va faire que ça
va
être des fois la nationale donc ça c'est
le très très gros projet pour septembre
on a le centre équestre qui est en cours
de réhabilitation donc qui alors pas le
centre équestre le hangar le lieu de
stockage du service technique voilà et
donc ça n'a pas empêché d'ailleurs de
continuer notre activité par la
solidarité de nos fournisseurs qui nous
ont prêtés du matériel le temps que les
assurances prennent le relais en tout
cas dès septembre les deux carrières
seront réhabiliter la cour des services
techniques sera réalisé donc une
activité je dirais flambant neuve pour
cette rentrée
2014-2015 donc dès septembre le nouveau
centre équestres on sera en fin de
travaux donc on inaugurera ces deux
éléments sportifs voilà que sont les
deux carrières qui sont très attendues
par les adhérents d'autres d'autres
projets alors oui on a on a
effectivement le centre de voile qui
maintenant est terminé donc qui pour la
première année dans son été va ouvrir
ses portes avec les nouveaux équipements
neufs avec de nouveaux bateaux de
nouveau de salle de séminaires de salle
de classe donc ça c'est c'est imminent
puisque ça fonctionne déjà en tout cas
c'est la nouveauté 2014 également et
puis on a une initiatique qui s'appelle
le baladen énigme alors ça c'est pour le
grand public c'est à dire qu'on pourra
venir chercher un petit document qui
nous permet de faire un grand jeu de
piste et éducatif sur l'ensemble de la
base qui vient compléter nos différents
parcours santé parcours d'orientation et
parcours bientôt d'interprétation
environnementale c'est quoi
l'interprétation environnement
à travers des bornes et au fur et à
mesure de notre parcours on a une
lecture paysagère avec des questions des
réponses
et on monte à 1 million dans les très
bonnes années donc j'espère que cette
année on est bien parti pour atteindre
ce
mois de juin qui est
correct mois d'avril également donc on a
bon espoir qu'on qu'on revienne à des à
des équilibres il y a 4-5 ans
et puis on vous souhaite un bon été
merci à vous d'être venu sur le plateau
du 7 8 week-end et puis je précise aussi
vous pourrez retrouver toutes les
activités de la base de loisirs dans un
prochain numéro de kiosque présenté par
Aurélia Debussy on va maintenant parler
du festival mémoire d'étoiles
alors le festival mémoire des toiles
c'est pas mémoire d apostrophe et toi
c'est mémoires des toiles toiles es
tout à fait bonsoir Éric Fauveau c'est
du 27 juin au 5 juillet c'est la 13e
édition donc de ce festival qui va se
dérouler au cinéma de Lagrange à
bois-d'arciste un festival de l'écrit à
l'écran c'est joli comme thème avec
comme thématique cette année la bande
dessinée la bande dessinée neuvième art
qui commence à de plus en plus existant
et reconnu à travers le monde des arts
et donc voilà donc on a décidé cette
année de faire un focus sur cet art
particulier qui est la bande dessinée où
il y a effectivement pas mal
d'adaptations cinématographique qui ont
été faites à différents niveaux de
qualité donc mais voyez quand même pas
mal de très bons films qui existent et
donc voilà on a fait une sélection d'une
quinzaine de films pour sur cette
thématique il y a plusieurs axes
de courant artistiques par rapport à la
BD on en a tiré quatre principaux qui
sont les mangas évidemment qui sont
l'école ce qu'on appelle l'école
franco-belge avec toutes ces BD qui sont
correspondante le cinéma d'animation
dans son grand ensemble et puis les
fameux super héros et les comics
américains qui ont fourni aussi de
nombreux de nombreux films aussi divers
ça ne peut que toucher un public très
large voilà on a essayé d'être le
maximum voilà une ouverture au maximum
au plus grand public puisqu'il y aura
des films pour tous les âges pour les
enfants pour les personnes plus âgées on
fait même une journée spécifique en tout
cas une séance spécifique qui sera
organisée par les enfants élus du
conseil municipal des jeunes des Didier
au seniors voilà pour faire un vraiment
une journée intergénérationnelle donc
voilà avec des films plutôt connus et
des films à découvrir ou à redécouvrir
ce qui est toujours le cas du festival
mémoire d'étoiles depuis 13 ans
maintenant il y a des projections donc
pour les scolaires on fait les poissons
pour les scolaires tous les enfants de
la ville donc primaire et maternelle ont
le droit et la chance de voir des films
spécialement dédiés alors niveau
jusqu'à on commence à la maternelle on
commence commencer à la maternelle quand
vous dites le niveau des films n'est pas
toujours le même c'est à dire
malheureusement c'est compliqué
d'adapter la bande dessinée au cinéma
pour les scénaristes puisque il y a déjà
ce qu'on appelle un storyboard il avait
fait déjà dessiné presque et c'est
peut-être ça les adaptations ces
matières sont données de d'exemple ça
donne des films qui sont pas forcément
d'une grande qualité voilà donc on a le
malheureusement beaucoup de films qui
sont pas terribles après voilà comme le
festival a quand même pour
but de me présenter des films de qualité
bien évidemment une sélection s'est
faite un peu naturellement faut savoir
qu'à peu près 300 à 400 films sur
l'histoire du cinéma qui sont
spécifiquement dédiés et spécifiquement
tiré des bandes dessinées
des quelques films qu'on peut citer sans
citer les 15 on va pas vous demander de
faire un choix
en fait ce soir
le soir parce qu'on fait ce qu'on
appelle un BD concert qui est quelque
chose d'assez assez original qui est
c'est comme un ciné concert sauf qu'au
lieu de se faire la pression d'un film
c'est la projection d'une d'un montage
vidéo
de la bande dessinée et donc ce soir
donc c'est au vent mauvais avec ma mis
en scène et surtout jouer à musique en
direct par le groupe The yens qui sont
les ex-mariés
et puis après voilà donc on a aussi la
chance donc ce sera lundi soir de
mémoire de projeter du monde du vent
dans les dans les mollets voilà de
Karine Tardieu qui sera présente ainsi
que Raphaël Moussafir qui est donc la
scénariste de la BD éponyme donc voilà
donc il y aura une rencontre à l'issue
de la projection et des séances de
dédicace à ceci il y a aussi une
exposition souvenir de film complètement
souvenir de film c'est organisé par quel
débile qui
un gros festival de bandes dessinées qui
se roule à Saint-Malo et il propose une
exposition qui est assez intéressante
qui est assez géniale je trouve puisque
ils ont fait une commande il y a
quelques années à une quarantaine
d'auteurs de BD actuels de redessiner
l'image du leur film préféré voilà donc
du coup ça donne des choses assez
étonnantes assez drôle assez dit qu'elle
est parfois et c'est plutôt intéressant
de redécouvrir les affiches vu le prix
de leur regard parfois un peu décalé
d'accord et donc en tout 38 auteurs
c'est ça en tout cas
un mot sur la journée de couture alors
j'en ai particulière donc le samedi 5
journée qui
qui sera donc festive puisque il y aura
des projections dès le matin pour ce
qu'on appelle le ciné bout de chou pour
les petits enfants de partir de 2 ans
parce que aussi ont le droit d'accéder
au cinéma en fait on aménage une salle
qui est très cocoon avec des petits
coussins donc voilà avec comme ça ils
sont vraiment en bonne situation
l'après-midi on fait une projection de
ma maman est en Amérique elle a attribué
hobbitine qui est sorti il y a 6 mois
avec la présence de Jean Regnault qui
est le scénariste avec aussi sans
dédicace et à partir de 19h jusqu'à
21h30 sur les maladies plein
d'animations de la musique un grand quiz
des caricaturistes qu'il a on croquer
les gens qui voudront partir avec leur
tronche un peu un peu déformée voilà
c'est le but
et puis à 21h30 on finit le festival par
la projection des alentours de Tintin de
Spielberg donc ça c'est le 5 juillet le
5 juin grande journée le 5 juillet et le
festival ça dure ça commence ce vendredi
soir et ça dure donc jusqu'au 5 juillet
oui et c'est entièrement gratuit et
voilà ce que je vais vous demander c'est
formidable donc c'est entièrement
gratuit toutes les séances sont
gratuites et les rencontres notamment
lundi soir avec Karine Tardieu sont
aussi gratuits
du festival mémoire d'étoiles le terme
est très jolie le nom du festival et
qu'il avait 13 ans
ce festival mémoire d'étoiles qui
démarrent ce vendredi soir et jusqu'au 5
juillet on va complètement changer de
sujet pour terminer le 7 8 week-end on
va parler de tir à l'arc oui mais le tir
à l'arc en 3D
et dans notre cible Philippe hoc bonjour
vous êtes président de la compagnie
d'arc d'Élancourt et de Laski c'est
comme ça c'est quoi la ski c'est l'arc
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines en fait ça
réunit les Cyclopes de Saint-Quentin il
y a Montigny voisin Guyancourt trap
Élancourt et
je pense en avoir oublié un mais je me
souviens plus lequel donc et c'est une
entente qui nous permet de de créer des
concours et de mettre à disposition
chaque club des du matériel gratuitement
alors pour la quatrième année la ski et
la compagnie d'arc de Manile amour
organise un concours en 3D tir à l'arc
c'est quoi la trois dimensions la 3D on
tire à l'arc le tir 3D en fait ce sont
des des animaux en mousse de taille
pratiquement réel avec des zones
marquantes et chaque participant de ou
attirer deux flèches sur ces animaux
avec la possibilité d'avoir un score
maximum de 22 points donc sur un
parcours complet il tire 46 avec une
pause déjeuner le midi ce qui est très
appréciable et cette année donc on est
sur un parcours exceptionnel puisqu'on
est dans les parcs des granges et des
ruines de Port-Royal avec un relief que
l'on n'a jamais eu jusqu'à présent et ça
complique la situation il est absolument
puisqu'on a arrivé à avoir des tirs avec
une descente ou un tir en hauteur et ça
change complètement la visée et ça nous
intéressait on avait jusqu'à présent que
des terrains plats et cette année c'est
c'est le musée qui est venu nous
chercher pour déjà animer aussi le site
ça leur permet de faire venir du monde
puisque le
le site ne sera pas fermé les visiteurs
pourront continuer à rentrer et
on a mis une tente d'explication je vois
Frédéric Bordier qui fait un geste genre
alors justement j'allais vous parler de
la sécurité ça veut dire que les gens
peuvent assister suivent le parcours des
tireurs qui sont quand même dans la
nature avec leur arc et leurs flèches
absolument on a rubalisé le terrain on
l'aura des flèches en plastique
ça peut aller jusqu'à tuer mais il faut
faire très attention et c'est
cette année on a quand même la double
sécurité à faire c'est à dire les
participants et les visiteurs donc mais
Yao aucun risque d'où on croise les
droits les doigts pardon mais je pense
que c'est
il y a aucun risque
en armure puisque le Royal
donc les armures
les cils sont à combien de mètres parce
que je présume que vous dis c'est des
c'est des animaux donc quand taille
réelle donc je sais pas il y a des
petits lapins des sangliers non oui
c'est ça va du du lapin du faisan au
sanglier
de taille réelle donc suivant les
catégories d'armes ça peut aller de un
tir de 5 jusqu'à 45 mètres
ont un viseur et ça arrange quand même
beaucoup les choses mais c'est
les tirs sont différents s'il y a la
descente et la montée et même avec un
viseur il y aura des des flèches qui
rend à côté de mètres
on va dire que sur une journée ils vont
faire 5 ou 6 km c'est vous qui avez
placé qui a placé les cibles alors oui
on est il y a du personnel qui fait le
parcours donc ça fait un mois qu'on est
dessus on choisit des zones un peu
compliquées et c'est que du des
personnes qui ne tireront pas le
concours qui place les cibles qui se
serait trop facile
donc les distances aussi on a un lasé on
prend tout ça au laser et on se recule
donc demain on aura un contrôle par les
arbitres qui vont valider les distances
valider la sécurité et donc dimanche
quand on va exécuter le concours
théoriquement ça sera qui arrive sur le
pas de tir ça pas du tout son placés les
cibles à aller sur le parcours arpenter
la forêt à la recherche du fameux animal
ce qu'on appelle un piquet d'attente qui
est en retrait donc les concurrents ils
sont cinq par peloton attend d'aspiquet
et avance vers l'empathie et c'est là
qu'il découvre la cible et la distance
donc c'est il y a aucun
triche qui puisse se faire c'est change
comme perception parce que je pense que
totalement différente entre le fait de
tirer sur une cible classique ronde que
de tirer là en pleine nature alors c'est
pas le même plaisir je présume pour les
tireurs
ça dépend de la philosophie qu'on voit
sur le tir à l'arc et c'est vrai que les
gens qui vont venir qui vont voir les
tireurs à payer un petit peu en chasseur
vont découvrir que c'est un peut-être un
aspect ludique du tir
du tir de chasse puisque les animaux on
les tue pas en fin de compte c'est de la
mousse et mais c'est peut-être des gens
qui ont l'esprit chasseur dans dans
l'âme
extrêmement sérieux parce que c'est un
concours fermé sélectif pour le
championnat de France 2014 c'est le
championnat régional donc c'est les
meilleurs tireurs de la région donc on
aura le champion de régional dans chaque
catégorie et c'est un concours qui est
sélectif pour le champion de France qui
aura lieu plus tard combien d'archers
qui nous impose un petit peu le nombre
de tireurs et on aura 176 tireurs
sachant qu'on pourrait aller jusqu'à 240
le rendez-vous des tireurs c'est à
partir de 7h le matin et je pense que le
site est ouvert à partir de 10 heures au
public puisque le seul musée qui gère ça
mais après les gens pourront se
renseigner sur une tente d'information
si certains veulent suivre un petit peu
le parcours il faut toujours demander à
quelqu'un de l'organisation pour les
accompagner
il y a de la rubalisation il faut jamais
revenir en arrière c'est surtout ça la
sécurité parce qu'il y a pas mal de gens
qui se promènent dans ce coin-là le
dimanche donc
on leur a demandé avec des affichettes
de bien respecter sur une balise donc
j'espère qu'ils seront sérieux et qu'ils
écoutentront mon conseil donc si vous
êtes amateur de tir à l'arc ou pas
amateur de tirl arc mais en tout cas
vous êtes curieux vous voulez découvrir
cette discipline du tir en 3D tire en 3D
rendez-vous dimanche du sur le site de
Port-Royal des Champs c'est à banni des
hameaux pendant que des grosses
discipline qui a l'air qui allie chasse
nature
et non pas du tout il y a pas de pêche
il y a de la tradition il y a de la
chasse il y a de la nature
merci en tout cas d'être venu sur le
plateau du 7 8 weekend et avant de se
quitter à l'envain j'étais comme
d'habitude un coup d'oeil sur l'agenda
de cette fin de semaine et les dates à
retenir parce qu'il y a aussi d'autres
animations ce weekend sur 50 ans en
Yvelines on va d'abord aller du côté du
musée de la ville pour un atelier dédié
à l'art du graffiti vous êtes invité à
participer à la réalisation d'une œuvre
collective et cela ne passe donc au
musée de la ville et puis dimanche
direction Versailles pour une
déambulation sur la RN 10 RD10 pardon
c'est la route départementale que les
automobilistes lyonnaises bien quand
elle tente Bouteiller le soir et qui
relie Saint-Cyr-l'École à Versailles et
qui pour l'occasion sera interdite aux
voitures alors ça sera un moment rien
que pour les piétons et les cyclistes
avec notamment une piste de skate du BMX
et un mur d'escalade avec une tour
Spello de 8 mètres pour ceux qui aiment
les sensations fortes et on pourra même
louer des vélos pour rouler
tranquillement sur la RD10 au musée de
Port-Royal Deschamps alors vous pouvez
aller voir du tir en 3D mais vous pouvez
aussi insister
samedi à une conférence débat sur
l'écriture au XVIIe siècle donc cela se
passe au musée de Port-Royal Deschamps
avec des spécialistes de la littérature
de cette époque et puis je on en a parlé
puisqu'on a reçu il fautvo sur ce
plateau le festival mémoire d'étoiles je
vous le rappelle c'est du 27 juin au 5
juillet ça se passe au cinéma de la
grange à la ferme de la tremblais à
Bois-d'Arcy c'est le 13e festival du
genre et cette année c'est sur le thème
de la BD au cinéma et pour finir un
tournoi d'improvisation
intergénérationnel organisé à trapa
Déclic Théâtre cela se passe samedi du
côté de l'école de musique et de danse
de la ville de Trappes l'entrée est à 3
euros voilà vous savez tout un week-end
riche en animation alors gardez l'esprit
ouvert et curieux et surtout bon weekend
à vous